citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for a Superman and not a man of steel
not a man of violence but a man of
Tomorrow we're very excited to dive into
a I think beginning of the tomorrow
verse is that how this works that's
right we skipped ahead with long
Halloween now we're going to the start I
like this I like this because we're into
several whole new universe we finished
the DC AMU and now we're at the
beginning of the tomorrow verse with the
man of Tomorrow much like Superman is
starting James Gunn's Universe we are
starting the tomorrow first with this
very excited to get into it uh please do
hit that notification Bell hit that like
button hit that comment board saying
like hey why'd you go back there what
are you doing this is what I want you to
do and you tell us what you want to do
because we may do it next it's all chaos
who knows and much like the man of
tomorrow's wisdom and insight and macro
perspective of the world you know who
else has that the patron yes because
much like Superman they see it all they
start at the beginning they go to the
end they experience every moment
including their resting face
those are our resting faces Superman's
probably a little bit more stoic but you
get my point so become a patron if you
want to see the entirety of the
experience much like he does but first
we are going to watch react and review
the man of Tomorrow starting right now
in three two
foreign
[Music]
there wasn't driving to start the Batman
one that's true but if the tomorrow
verse starts with driving I would say
that's a precedent yes so maybe the DC
AMU was drive heavy let's find out if
the overall tomorrow verse will be yeah
yeah
snatched
[Music]
a disappointment aliens are scary aren't
you glad they're not real
little on the nose jeez man thanks for
calling Deb it wasn't even that
excuse it gets a little jittery ah pause
understanding man good man paw he spends
every waking minute trying to get that
thing to work he lifted a tractor with
one finger Martha he was gonna figure it
out
whoever put him in that ship had no idea
or care for how dangerous a world they
were sending them to the more he knows
the more he can protect himself and US
knowledge is power
when in doubt just try to slam it on the
ground that's uh that's how I saw my
Rubik's Cube
[Music]
now I really do have to get to work
everyone's counting on me I'm a big part
of the team covering today's launch
you'll read about it tomorrow on The
Daily Planet I love you bye I signed an
NBA bye wait till let's follow here
there you go you kept my secret but you
can't keep this one okay
oh
spook
a latte no whip and I hope you don't
mind I had them add a dash of cinnamon
to the grinds it really wakes it up
Superman off coffees tomorrow and uh you
don't actually have to call me baby boy
Kevin
I would love if this Superman was really
just an expert on coffee just knows
because you can see the grind he's like
you know this could use genetically you
know I roasted these beans with my heat
they're about to launch the most
sophisticated
store lips how you built that rocket
with
other Hefty government contract this
President knows a good investment when
he sees it does he know fraud fraud who
sees it not the question I expected Lois
your internship is over Lois
billion
oh no looks like you could use this more
than me oh Lifesaver cinnamon really
wakes it up
cinnamon soups
boy it's gonna have to do some Superman
you got this SpaceX it'll be fine it
always goes very well I've seen stuff
s our weapons
x-ray vision I'd say somebody already
knows we're not alone in the universe
did just have that hearing it was very
it was something all right sure did
happen I protect my people I think
you're the one that might need
protecting
two tours in Iraq I know a [__] I don't
want to see it yeah someone's interested
in you kid I Want You Back who are you R
Jones yeah Rick Jones is in Marvel but
this man seems important like are you
gonna become another Hank Henshaw on me
clever
it's a bird it's an exploding that's our
impending do
oh no you gotta be kidding me
oh he's not in Superman at all yet wow
he's this guy with beanie yeah
and goggles
let's go beanie goggle man yeah that's
not the same ring too but we're getting
there we're shopping it's all good
[Music]
wow cool scope I'm loving this so far
yeah that's great this has been really
solid
also no full origin but like a solid
origin story yeah no yeah you get the
theme the Thematic qualities of it
feel the energy absorb it Neo
freaking crooked legs 15 years
I would say hero after that rocket event
perhaps it's pretty obviously saved
Millions
meet the newest addition to the team the
grand
regret a billionaire genius an actual
talent low slang
it's a good way to boost morale and
build a team that's uh better than all
you idiots will ever be Lois by the way
just Lois cool and you are oh I'm coffee
uh Clark
I'm coffee boy
how did you do it people with that much
power think they wielded over everyone
if you can take that away from them for
a moment you can take it away for good
any other questions
if you're gonna be a reporter kid you
got to ask all the questions what do you
do now you've already taken down the
most powerful man in the world have I oh
dedicated life to taking down Superman
now the Menace oh oh I like her naming
him in this yeah cool Cape that name's
not gonna stick as well the
[Laughter]
love it that's delightful and put a Big
C on your chest for coffee boy
get a brown jacket an unidentified
object
what do you know Brian Cranston tell us
your secrets Rick Jones Rick Jones
oh what happened to Mike Jones what did
happen to Mike Jones
leave in the comments let us know what
happened to Mike Jones oh your cape my
dude
come back for it my Kent's got to sell
it for him yeah that's true
this is
holy [__]
my man oh man why are you
are you Kryptonian of course I never
heard an old flying Kryptonian but what
ifs
oh yeah
yes we're doing this the fun way yes
Superman is about fun Above All Else
gotta be mamawa it's just the momoaist
character or ever to Momoa yeah for a
second I thought it was his voice I was
like what year is this we're we're
planning ahead yeah
electricals Electro leeches
[Music]
woof this planet is protected alien they
ain't got mirrors on this dump you're as
alien as they come Round Here Kryptonian
I'm a Kryptonian
no last one in the universe tucked away
in sector 2814. you got an awful big
bounty on that stupid looking head of
yours oh I guess that means you have to
bring me in alive Bounty Hunter names
Lobo and no
of course no
no frag the [__] out of me
you know what you really wanted to say
wow
[Music]
oh cool
I hope them pants hold on Clark
got Goblin glidered a little cool new
take in the origin making him like not
know what he is until the villain tells
him and it makes sense someone Cosmic
like Lobo yeah someone with a bounty to
fill her perhaps he's trying to move the
fight to safer ground
I mean that tracks with the modern you
know sensibilities I think he's going to
be Green Lantern oh I mean he kind of
looks like him
yeah I think you're probably right right
the name threw me but everything else
points to
he could have changed his name you never
know
come on help him I wonder
can you see in the dark
[Music]
parasite Maybe
I had good reach on that knee
ah
we got a Dragon Ball Z fighting her
hands here folks
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
he's gonna keep making wild guesses
Martian manhunters that guy gay okay
okay but seeing how it was Krypton
itself killed your people carved from
the remains of that doomed Rock should
be the thing to mess you up oh no
for a second I was like is lobo Green
Lantern
what a Twist what a weird choice
damn
whoa
there's a lot going on yeah how about
this
yeah it was
wow cool
[Music]
all right
got a phase man
yes
drink your solar berry juice
yes super booty
Buns of Steel
[Music]
this was the fun way
who needs a
cape man
your Junk's been on TV now
yeah this Cannon's very different they
uh they let your friends stay naked
throughout
I wish I was so loved that
everyone's too busy to notice his face
it'd be great that's how the glasses
work yeah it's just dogs out the whole
time it's the doctor Manhattan Theory
no one looks up because I'm like whoa
best disguise we got a little
it's never gonna catch on
uh you took down Luthor and now you're
doing an expose on the flying man I'm
winning a Pulitzer for my revelatory
takedown of the alien who calls himself
the Superman no you call him he's
calling himself exactly it's an
interesting lowest take in this movie
edgy Lois they meet someone from the
stars and their first instinct is to
fire at will they love you they don't
know me
you can either either meet it head on
and accept the consequences or you can
keep your head down and accept the
consequences but you have to make one
it's fair advice what the hell happened
to this guy
I'm gonna close them back up
no yep
no oh
oh
absorb their life force
parasite I've come for your son sir
unless you want to show us some
credentials I think we're done here I'm
sorry
sorry whoa
[Music]
whoa
get inside lock the doors locked Gates
against this aliens yeah yeah [__] our
wooden door against a man faster than me
you another Bounty Hunter
yeah
so cool
yes I am no Bounty Hunter but I am a man
Hunter my name
is John
and I only wish to speak with you why
didn't you say so and look this Superman
believes him he doesn't just fight for
no reason it's almost like he's Superman
oh goodness what no koi when is he gonna
level a city court I mean faith in
mankind who has it or alien con Martian
kind yeah drugs
I'm sorry without prescription I can't
help you but there is a clinic nearby
where you can get detoxed oh
I love the colors of his little yeah
Power striations John is
good night love that her for attraction
a slipper party yep yeah why not it's
the first time I'm a martian guys
there's someone who friends with Clark
he must stay for breakfast when I first
became aware that your possess abilities
similar to my own I assumed pot you were
Martian oh I attempted a telepathic link
between our minds and in doing so I
inadvertently accessed your memories of
Krypton you were only an infant
oh yeah
oh
nice
I've never been able to make this thing
work
wow I love how important he is in this
Martian Manhunter being like the
positive to lobo's negative yeah
is that your parents but you should know
that the last thing your mother ever
said to you was that to dwell in the
past
to lose one's path so don't learn
anything about yourself
mom's wishes how will I find you
just listen
cool yeah what a great Ambassador
character and it suits them like it's
the perfect way to introduce them so
what is it
I don't know some kind of historical
record you can do almost anything go
anywhere
only
oh you can go anywhere but as all those
photos posted all over the world show
your clothes can't yep
my kids respecting your dignity as your
dong splattered across every major
newspaper has proven mother I do not
approve put your super buns away you
were swaddled in it when we oh
I met an old female in heat stop
stop what is wrong with you
why don't I show ya come on girlie
oh yes
kryptonians the whole Army coming just
for him [__] don't care who they got
a little fighter get him sod just
kidding they're all dead you should have
seen the look on your face though damn
she really met her match and it's Lobo
yeah Lobo versus Lois let's do it and
then I'll give you a little bit of wham
bam about
it really is half the Appalachian mating
dance
or a young Michael Rooker sure God how
great would that be oh oh boy Whoa man
you're not looking so good
dude don't stop filming no
uh
-huh
[Music]
nice I love a good body withering gag I
do like the coloring too though it's
really clever yeah
what have I done he's gonna have moments
of clarity I imagine yeah
whoa whoa
oh no
whoa what has he become
oh yeah you became the Cloverfield
monster yes he did this is the secret
prequel
that's what it's exactly the kind of
thing Cloverfield would do
long game WB crossover WB bot slusho you
know this uh animated movie from like a
decade or more ago secretly a
Cloverfield now you know oh he's got the
undies oh under Rose and the belt
we're overdue for That interview maybe
when this is over
I'll be there no games I promise no
power plays
oh yeah save us Tom Cruise it's a train
yes
whoa
[Music]
laughs
oh
yeah
oh it looks like you're cooking them how
we doing John
he's learning
oh wow
oh he is gonna be still wrong
looking a little doomsday there bud yeah
I was thinking that
internally
the interns
oh no no
where are you John
oh boy
I'm glad you have gloves oh they don't
help okay take it back
no
please
no they didn't they didn't what they
wouldn't he's so good in this universe
no
wow
save him cold breath does he know he has
Cobra no
wow the best Martian Manhunter we've had
I know he was great I'm legitimately
bummed they did the thing where they
made them great so they kill him make us
feel things but I don't like it because
he's Jon Jones he said like more screen
time than the rest of the movies
combined and like greater impacts and
now he's oh
why do they hate him so much
foreign
interesting yeah I mean that absorption
must have Zapped a lot of his residual
energy
it burned him alive Lois that parasite
thing I can still hear the screams and
the Superman I think he's dead too yeah
see what you did with your expose it's
all your fault Lois this job take
smarter than you for help
I bet they're closer than you think
you're totally right
perfect
oh good great writing I need your help
I've seen you in action fly boy you're
as powerful as a locomotive more
[Music]
I need to get into space the sun it's
like a power source for you isn't it and
if you need help getting closer to it
that means you're powerless
that's why he's so smart he's just like
oh your son must be not not space itself
how much do you want no I don't want
anything but to help it can only look
good to the parole board
sure but I can't help you from in here I
have to get out that's not going to
happen Luthor I can get a day pass
that's not even a thing one a bet
you're a billionaire all the president
make a write me a Lex Luthor one time
day pass it's just a monopoly get out of
jail card yes 24 hours I had it
notarized it's official all right there
you go
fast I can't find my
zombie oh I worry about them now this is
gonna be fine dudes and everything goes
well everything yeah no it's totally oh
that looks different now hey let me fix
this bra Cloverfield monster
oh
this is from Star Labs how did you get
this yep
that grenade was an organic EMP designed
to absorb all the power it comes in
contact with it's almost like it melded
with the janitor's DNA and turned him
into some kind of energy vampire wow
it's like buying a company when you
absorb the assets you also absorb the
vulnerabilities if we can employ those
we can defeat it oh smart what are
Superman's weaknesses
oh geez clever you might say I bought
the company Robo is now my asset
or vulnerability
so good great use of Lex this plant
Powers the entire city where is
everybody I called in a bomb threat
before we left you shouldn't lie about
bombs what if it saves many lives I
didn't
[Music]
my man
Zang
whoa nice
wowie Cloverfield freaking Kaiju
that helped him last time yeah man whoa
you can learn that power I was gonna say
I wonder if parasite will help him learn
some of his latent Powers paying you to
stand around yeah yeah don't get your
eyes in a Twist who is his voice it's
great
it's kind of sounds like I feel like it
can't be but
woof
Pacific Rim Lobo
oh my God no it looks like there's a
limit to how long the parasite can
retain your power and weakness gotta let
him absorb you again
what
wow they're murking people in this
tomorrow versus like we're not here for
a long time we're here for a good time
we're only here for like five or six
movies take a lot out in the beginning
oh boy oh boy
no oh man what a well done shot just
line up so he can hit us all let him
play pool with us
no
she's just getting his gains
give him a weakness
atta boy hey
want some more I'm right here eat me you
should get the ring first though yeah
[Music]
the definitive Godzilla oh no
I wonder if they have him no ah I mean
something's going on there
my prize
oh my God see here see here problem the
parasite is very powerful but the
Superman is also very powerful damn you
yeah there it is I'll just make you both
my slaves
oh
that's gonna hurt on the way down
oh yep yep
Lex Corp security issue pretty sweet huh
you had that thing made up fast
hey yes
redeemed I was getting real worried are
you all right put the parasite I saw it
kill you this is a comic book Kalel no
one dies you saw what I wanted it to see
uh
someone did Drive yep I feel better
about it here we go finally cars the
true heroes of the DC Universe
what do you think you're gonna do oh Lex
Lois Lane live at the scene we're on
foot and we have a phone so we're live
streaming the military have tried to
keep the crowd back the family's always
on a car near the danger
parasite can absorb our strength
knowledge our feelings our Essence
oh feelings
I know you're still in that room
tutti frutti oh Rudy
you've gotten my heart my love for my
family and friends
Rudy you're a combat veteran who served
with honor
Rudy proud father one in first grade
Kaylee right
and another on the way oh my parents
Hope was that they had sent me to a
world where I would be safe and
protected but the price of that
protection Silence about who and what I
really am good zoom on that I was scared
but I'm not scared anymore my name is
calell of Krypton
and I come in peace and I am Iron Man
oh
no Rudy still available
Rudy come on oh oh he just wants to see
them
Rudy
no no no no no no no no no no no you are
human no
no no no no no no
no no
oh no
think altruistic thoughts yeah right
think about your family
oh God
oh God uh oh oh no I wonder if he has to
absorb it then he just like over I don't
know I don't know what's gonna happen I
love that I don't know
altruistic parasite
wow find the Good Will of Superman great
scope shot
[Music]
tell you what metropolis's electric
Bill's gonna go Skyrocket
whoa
this is gonna be gooey
[Music]
oh
calcified
I kind of love that even Superman and
Jon Jones combined couldn't take out
parasite
wow
I'll be ours Dust in the Wind you could
have mentioned the immortality I like to
keep people guessing sure
we bought it yeah aliens the last
surviving members of each of our peoples
two capes so I killed all my people
people self it's what do I give a [__]
so my origin is technically different
nah
ah just kidding you should have seen
your face though
I love him I love him so much you know
those are just stories right every rat
bastard I hunt is the last of his people
something you say to keep the Bounty hot
are you saying there are other martians
out there hell yeah seen him myself
might even be a Kryptonian or two yeah
there might oh it might be a carazarel
out there who knows you should go follow
him find your people and you Kalel
it's Superman
my people are right here oh you couldn't
meet me over by the stairs or losing
valuable interview time sorry Miss Lane
not today
power play power play
Superman Our Man Of Tomorrow nice
uh you know what I told you about power
moves Clark well I was right they really
do work has anybody seen my calendar
[Music]
[Applause]
that's George
[Music]
Ah that's my Superman I really enjoyed
that from the jump that's my Superman I
loved that that was delightful and
lovely and well orchestrated all around
and everyone complaining online that you
can only have a Superman movie with just
Superman to start well look what we did
oh well yeah it's like that felt like a
Superman movie it felt like it set the
character up obviously but it also
wasn't Ensemble you got a couple other
powers
I feel like they were stealing Focus or
you know diluting things Darren Chris
could not play some Ryan Hurst is lobo
okay that tracks that's great Alexandra
Daddario
man okay good voice that's wonderful and
like not the you know go-to everyone
thinks of blank like Ryan Hurst is
usually Thor in my head or Sons of
Anarchy sure no yeah I really like the
voice cast across the board in this and
I mean we've talked about
you know just different takes on the
characters and whatnot and uh and we've
spent a lot of time with who was that
like Jerry O'Connell or was uh Superman
in the AMU but um but yeah no I mean I
really liked the way they personified
pretty much everybody and I mean even
like I wonder how this the Clark and
Lois relationship will develop over the
tomorrow verse yeah um because that's
that's the thing is like you know that
feels still very much like it's at the
beginning of their story yeah yeah yeah
and I mean I still like there's a
certain amount like I don't know exactly
what the definitive
yeah I know Lois Lane to be like a
spunky character certainly like a
hard-hitting journalist obviously but uh
you know she had like kind of a you know
like an edge in this movie but that is
also kind of you know being opened to
the benevolence yeah she's always been
like I'll do anything for the story but
never hurt anybody and that it's kind of
fun to see you know a go-getter Lois
Lane separate of Clark in the beginning
and I also love that
they're doing An Origin that doesn't
feel like an origin which I always love
when they can do but also that everyone
kind of has their arcs like everyone
grows through the movie like everyone
changes a bit and and that was like 10
lead characters that was really well
done and also Superman starts as
Superman like this is how I love to see
Superman he's so altruistic he's so you
know his his humor comes from being just
so wholesome and good he didn't feel
overpowered which is really impressive
to do an origin movie where Superman
doesn't feel op one I like that the
ultimate there is a lot of fighting but
it's not the ultimate solution is we
just had to you know fight the [__] out
of this yeah and I liked it as much as
they they clearly you know a parasite is
a is it already existing character as
well but it seems like they don't seem a
lot but it seems like yeah they took
that character and then combined
elements of the Doomsday plot because
you know he's absorbing like part of his
link to Superman is the key to defeating
doomsday but then that's not even the
actual solution here you know it's and
it's a sacrifice it's an appeal I
thought that was such a great
choice to have it be like oh not only do
you absorb the power you absorb the
vulnerability and you absorb the heart
the the disposition of who you've just
taken on and that leads to the key and
yeah it's not a perfect rap round like
oh he gets to have his family back but
he does make a sacrifice you know with
that last Moment of clarity for his
family yeah 2020 so this is pretty
recent okay sure uh I also really like
that this was a Superman movie like you
mentioned parasite but this didn't have
doomsday didn't have Lex is the big bad
didn't have like it wasn't your usual
suspects but it uses The Usual Suspects
well like Lex is definitely nefarious in
a douche nozzle and like you definitely
have uh really wonderful
characterization of all these these
characters that you can grow with but
also Superman didn't just punch his way
to solve it like Superman didn't defeat
him no like this was so good like this
was a great yeah this was a great like
sort of first few days on the job kind
of story for me and I loved you know the
way they did man paw I loved the little
prologue I love the way that they're
watching the a alien movie and there are
themes that tie around both for Cal but
also for Martian Manhunter for uh John
in this movie and even I mean like
lobo's such a boisterous character but
even he you know has some kind of
overlapping commonality with them being
that he is an alien uh and I loved just
like the the continuing reversals with
him the whole you know you should just
eat your face and I really liked that
there was a uh negative alien influence
and a positive alien influence for Clark
I really liked that there was a mentor
in in John and then there was like the
the Lobo hunting him and how you've got
like the different uh pressures of being
someone discovering your powers with
aliens and how much he has to absorb and
just deal with but he's Clark so he's
navigating it like that was great yeah
and I mean seeing him like I love the uh
the preliminary suit with just like the
bomber jacket and the beanie yeah and
the way the people need to sort of
acclimate and come around to and sort of
they have all these questions about like
well you know it seems like he's here to
help us but is he really here to help
purpose and the whole like power play
thing coming full circle like this is
this was so rich man and 2020 means like
you know this is all really recent and
we've got a bunch more I I the animation
wasn't quite as Rich
um there were a couple moments where I
definitely noticed they had to like
creatively Zoom or crop and like did you
know some interesting stuff but overall
I preferred this take on Superman I'm
really excited to see these origins of
you know characters I love in this new
world like that there's some really
intriguing options to go from here yeah
absolutely like I thought this was like
earlier than it was but yeah 2020 like
just happened yeah and and yeah what a
great sort of it does have that archery
thing like the the animation at times
does remind me a little bit of Archer
but I do love their establishing shots
like I love their Metropolis design I
loved A lot of the stuff in Smallville
just like the I thought they were still
able to ring a good amount of tone or
like you know that one shot where
parasite is turning to go to the big
reactor yeah you get that like Pacific
Rims oh cool like I found the the way
they used time for him like being slow
and then the leap that was so fun yeah
totally like and there are a lot of you
know obviously little cheeky
superman-esque nods but yeah it's like
even if the animation I feel like
animation over time has certainly become
a medium sort of affected by like well
we can't dump as much money into this as
we used to so yeah it's like I'm I'm
willing to be forgiving of those same
things and I think that that this is an
example of a movie where despite some of
those like you know budget constraints I
still think like the conception of so
many of the images and uh and the mood
of so many of the other in that so many
of the images really translates and most
of all I can't shake the fact that you
know we're getting a Superman movie live
action that's going to be introducing us
to a New Lex a new Lois a new Jimmy but
also we just found out a Mr terrific a
uh you know Guy Gardner uh Green Lantern
a
um who else did they announce for sure
for sure hot girl and metamorpho yeah so
that's a lot and that can be done this
was 90 minutes this was very short and
they did a lot of World building and
they did a lot of establishing and it
didn't feel rushed and didn't feel like
they lost Superman to that it felt like
a world was already formed which is one
of the strengths of the DC to me is like
we're gonna have a fully formed DCU yeah
absolutely and I mean I think there's a
Justice Society movie in the in the
continuity after this one but I love it
yeah a little you get like a little
reference to Batman who then we'll see
in the long Halloween and then you get
yeah it's like it's got enough super
characters and things in the foreground
and then enough sort of things to hint
that the world is bigger without forcing
it to go all those places in the first
installment yeah like yeah this is
establishes so lovely and yeah it draws
so many nice little like Inspirations
from across the pantheon I would imagine
and uh and yeah manages to do it while
feeling I I I think I like four stars
for me yeah absolutely and I and I love
the origin also that yeah he's
discovering stuff he doesn't have all
the memories Ma and PAW don't have the
means to get his full story uh John
helps him with a little uh codex you
know pyramid thingy like oh I love that
I love that amazingness he's got like a
mentor love that John didn't die in a
you know well Jonathan didn't die in a
tornado accident he gets to stick around
a little while I had a really
interesting moment when I I uh there was
a rumor going around that Brendan Fraser
might be pocket and one perfect I mean I
would love that two Redemption for
Batgirl three uh my most interesting
take was a lot of people were like yeah
but pocket dies and I was like
huh the average person thinks of
poquette as a dead character as I think
of him as living like to me Superman can
always fly over to Kansas and visit
mompaw Kent and uh because of Smallville
and the Snyder World though those only
two continues I think of pot Kent is
dying that young like Paul Kent does
eventually die in the comics but he's in
the comics for decades okay yeah and
like he's in the comics right now like
he's alive in the comics right now so
like I would keep Brennan Frazier alive
but I I think the average viewer knows
the biggest TV Universe at Smallville
and the biggest movie universe as Snyder
they don't think about Ken is alive well
and maybe in a visual media it's an easy
I feel like there's an emotional easy
emotional trauma choice to be like my
mentor my father he's dead now you know
keep him alive keep hot Kent alive this
time James again and they're gonna make
us trauma enough that he's gonna make us
cry some animals gonna get hurt no no
yeah if anybody I think it can ring the
uh the the more nuanced version of you
know like what if we meet Superman with
crypto oh my God because James Gunn
loves animals what yes crypto's on the
on the ship with him oh my crypto dude
yeah that's sent to be your protector
dude if we get crypto Ace like another
animal I mean obviously detective chimp
detective chips and then Super Pets 2
happens because that movie was
surprisingly great uh but yeah this was
delightful I I really really had a good
time with that love this uh well
lovelies uh we are now in the tomorrow
verse I do believe our plan it could
change but our plan will be to dive into
it looks like Justice Society World War
and that'll connect us right to the long
Halloween which we've already watched so
check out the long Halloween videos part
one and two uh we want to get you guys
to see this whole tomorrow verse with us
and remember if you want us to keep
doing these please do like subscribe
notification Bell share post us on
forums tell your friends tell your
family tell your dad who loves Superman
hey there's this great movie and these
guys you don't know are watching it you
just watch it with them and they'll be
like that's crazy it's a weird thing to
do also be a patron so you'd be like hey
let's watch them pause and think about
their where they've been and what
they've become please do check all those
out and uh we want to keep doing these
so check out the whole playlist we're
gonna keep diving through and next up
should be Justice Society anything last
uh say to the folks no just a more naked
Superman
steel more Buns of Steel and who else
had butts of parasites parasites or Buns
of Steel and parasitic butts coming soon
to the Tamara verse maybe after long
Halloween we get some bat butts you know
who's got the greatest glutes in the
entire DC Universe
Nightwing oh sure oh cannons no it's
actually like a running joke no
Nightwing literally like covers are
drawn of him with that but that
badonkadonk
but it's about the other side he's the
one hero who only does legs he is a man
of scarves whatever he's like I got
these two batons but they're really
waited for my squat game because
Nightwing he wields some gray Suns if
you know what I'm saying uh all right
that is gonna do it for this episode of
koi likes Nightwing's butt and we will
see you next time it's a great butt
super good butt much love y'all
thank you